jamie-lynn Sigler marries MLB Pro cutter
Dykstra and et has all the details from
their desert chic wedding the sopranos
alum is officially mrs. Dykstra the
couple wed on Saturday at the Parker
Hotel in Palm Springs California
surrounded by 150 of their closest
friends and family the bride walked down
the aisle looking breathtaking in a
stunning Oscar de la Renta gown Jamie
wore her hair up with a long veil
attached to her bun Ziggler's groom was
simply dapper in a classic black brooks
brother tux and matching bow tie the
couple's adorable two-year-old son Beau
and the family dog beam were part of the
ceremony walking out before the actress
made her big reveal singer land fast
officiated his besties wedding the
former in singstar was a bit indecisive
about his outfit before the ceremony
tweeting do I go with space socks or
sloth socks Lisa Vanderpump respond in
writing and no onesies looks like he
took her advice looking sharp in a dark
gray suit the newlyweds exchanged vows
not long before sunset and received a
big applause after being pronounced
husband and wife what a romantic start
to their happily ever after